we had a massive blackout for the first
time ever in the middle of the episode
and then as soon as that happened the
energy changed and he got you know
buttoned up again he went to the
bathroom he was kind of nervous he
probably thought this was the end he
thought when that blackout I was gonna
take out a little gun and shoot him and
Cheryl in the head that's probably what
he thought
for you know for a minute when
everything went black for a minute in
that guy's head there's no way he didn't
sink I'm gonna get killed by this fat
idiot now after everything this guy's
gonna launch himself over the desk and
kill me and my wife